let's make the almost inconceivable  nanoworld  conceivable the naked eye can see the  diameter of a human hair that's 1/10 of  a millimeter or 100,000 nanometers to  understand the small we're going to  scale it up to skyscraper proportions  and return to our human hair and blow it  up to the size of the Empire State  Building a typical human cell say a red  blood cell would rise to the 10th floor  a bacterial cell the 3rd floor working  down our scale a run-of-the-mill protein  molecule would be the same height as a  small dog about a foot and a half and a  nanometer on our empire state scale it's  less than a quarter of an inch that's  about the size of five microscopic atoms  placed end-to-end